you
[Music]
I'm Samir and I'm really excited to talk
to you about the AI challenges in
customer care automation so when we are
shopping we are generally shopping
expectations from any kind of e-commerce
store is something like a physical store
we pretty much think that the kind of
services service that kind of personal
attention that we get from physical
store will be similar as we shop in
e-commerce store but in reality our
stores are somewhat like this most of
the time shopping online for most of the
stuff of course we go to the physical
locations too but I think a lot of
commerce is happening online these days
and the problem is that the personal
touch is missing in many cases if you go
to a small store for example it was very
small store you pretty much know the
store owner and the store owner no Zoe
and he knows a lot about you he might
recommend your product he might help you
make a return and then you know do some
chitchat and so on if it's a larger
store then there are sales people out
there and they will help you out doing
returns and recommend stuff and so on
but in such ecommerce store this
personal touch is missing totally
missing and that's where customer care
automation comes in so customer care
automation the sole purpose of customer
care automation is to provide happiness
or basically keep the customer happy and
make a customer a repeat customer but
when you think of customer care
automation a customer can talk in
talking multiple channels they can talk
on Facebook on Twitter on alexa on
google home and so many so many more
places and that's where when there are
so many channels and if you start
thinking about it
the way customer care happens is that
basically it's a question-answering
system but there are so many different
channels out there then these channels
break because how you are going to
respond to all of these all these multi
channels but then every
question answering and now if you look
at the kind of questions that people ask
those questions are totally variated I
mean it could be very specific
specifically about a product they might
say that can I make a return it could be
about your company it could be also be
about you know can I get a refund when I
can when I'm getting a refund and people
sometimes are upset and but if you go to
a store physical store somebody if
you're upset somebody's going to you
know not very nicely very politely to
you and you know because they want to
keep your other customer but that
doesn't seem to happen in e-commerce
stores right so if you look at these
kind of questions and then if you look
at some of the solutions out there the
solutions right now are mostly centered
around some knowledge bases like if you
have some product then you tell about ok
the product does does this and that and
this is this is my return policy this is
how the tracking happens and so on and
in fact the kind of questions if you are
looking at them they are less than 10%
of them you can answer through a regular
question answering system regular
knowledge base systems the reality is
that you have to have both the knowledge
based systems and you also need to have
a workflow based kind of system once you
have these two systems then you can
pretty much have a mechanism in place by
which your question answering system
will work based because you can look up
some of the things right there into the
database you can take some of the
actions that you have to take when you
have workflow kind of mechanism out
there but the problem with workflow kind
of mechanism is it is too brittle for
example if you have a chat bot which is
on alexa or facebook messenger and now
it starts you create a mechanism for
let's say one company let's say
characters or something then it's going
to break for another company because
they have a different workflow for
returns maybe some people some companies
have 30-day return policy some companies
have 60 days I'm have probably a
Nordstrom some somebody might have like
probably help Andy a life long policy so
all these things need to be looked up
and they need to be hooked up
specifically for that particular store
and that's where these systems tend to
break
now if I go back to some of the common
use cases so these are the use cases in
general that are there which are
tracking frequently asked questions
returns and reorder these are the very
common use cases these are the evolving
ones which are happening for customer
care automation which are product
recommendations checking product
availability checking nearby stores and
people are started asking all of this
questions on facebook messenger on on
Google home and Alexa and so on and if
you take again you look at what our
actual goal was the actual goal was to
on multi-channel provide different
services so that you keep the customer
happy and you keep the philosophy the
original spirit of the physical store
alive I mean that was the whole purpose
but you have so many channels and things
are breaking apart and this is the
problem over here because there's so
many services that you want to cater to
there's so many knowledge bases you want
to look up and that's where AI comes in
because you want to connect all of them
all of these services together into a
cohesive whole so that you can give that
personalization that kind of service to
the to the end customer now if I look at
that current ml scenario cannot current
AI scenarios they are I mean you already
know of some of them we have the deep
learning
you have the CNN lsdm by LST m and you
know so many other algorithms out there
we are the standard machine learning
algorithms SEM random forests and you
know a lot of other similar types of
course we have the rule-based systems
that are there and now if I look at the
challenges that are there in such kind
of now this is the I just spoke about
the different kinds of AI machinery or
AI algorithms now the challenges here in
the customer care related to NLU
understanding the intent itself of what
the user is saying understanding what
the sentiment of the user is
understanding the basically taking all
the user data and marrying it
the NLU and also understanding the
product itself the product
disambiguation and integrating all the
workflows so these are the in broad
level these are the different challenges
out there for for customer care
automation and we all know everybody
over here I think most of the guys over
here are you know in data science and
engineering and so on that you have to
follow the data but the problem is the
data exists in silos in many places in
most of the companies this data exists
in silos you have to take all of that
data and the labeling itself is a
problem because sometimes it's not
labeled data and sometimes the data is
so small and but it is evolving category
and then you have to make sure that you
are able to label it correctly and so
these are the problems that you know
kind of you get into that once you start
into the data engineering part of it and
once you take all of that data you have
to present it to some of your AI
algorithms then only they will make
sense of it and creating a very
extensible architecture around it is
generally very difficult and we did need
to have a very deep level integration
for example like if you are talking
about return policies if you are talking
about tracking you have to know which
for example tracking you need to know
that of this particular company they use
FedEx over there they use USPS or UPS to
send stuff now if it's return policy you
need to basically hook into their return
systems you need to understand the
return policies and how their workflow
happens and so on so it requires a very
deep level of integration and now that
part sanchez going over the different
kinds of issues the different kinds of
problems are there and now we get into
the come back to some of the major
challenges the intent so all of these
the intent has multiple multiple issues
with intent humans tend to speak in
multiple intents we generally don't say
tracking now we don't say like that what
we say is that oh where is my item I was
tracking for this it's so late and now
it's Christmas and I am really so upset
and so on I mean that's what people tend
to say and
I mean it's too mechanical for us to
expect from people that they will also
say like tracking returns I mean right
now people are doing it but actually
that's not the perfect way the perfect
way is that they talk the way they
should talk to another human and that's
what like the intern comes in we talk in
multiple intents when we have multiple
intents then we have to find out which
of the intent is more important and we
have to have a very high level of
accuracy for that for example you don't
want to return something that you don't
want to return you just part of maybe
very cool camera and certainly you said
something in your robot thought that all
you have to return this and just send
you a return label
of this cool camera that you bought so
you need to have a very high accuracy
over here and a very false positive a
very small false positive rate and
typically it is less than 3% false
positive is what you are looking for the
other problem is that you might talk
multiple intents now how to sequence
those intents for example I might say oh
I really like I don't really like this
product at this particular pair of shoes
that I bought I want to return it or
maybe it's possible can I get it in the
nearby store do you have a local address
that I can go to or maybe I can get it
earlier because you are us UPS takes
long to come come over to my place
that's a very complex sentence for a
machine to understand because the
Machine now needs to know that these are
so many intents out there he wants to
return this he probably wants to
exchange it he wants to get a refund he
wants to get a nearby store and so there
are so many things that the machine
needs to understand before it gets to a
level where the user is comfortable and
goes ahead with whatever the machine is
recommending so in the intent mapping of
course you can have a choice of
algorithms but again the choice there
because of the higher in the requirement
for very high accuracy you have to kind
of take a mix of both you have the
regular deep learning approach but that
is not enough in many cases you have to
go deeper in NLP as well you have to go
into deeper into computational
linguistics to understand basically
dependency graphs and and so on and
understand what the user is saying and
make some rules out of that and also
marry it to the
plodding approach and that is how
probably the actual intent mapping might
work then we come to it so intent is
done we move over to the sentiment
analysis so you have to understand
sentiment as well over here a sentiment
is that's a good thing that it's
actually a pretty much solved problem
and I think they're really good
algorithms out there which which help
you understand what is the sentiment of
the user and so on but the problem
arises is when do you really take an
action when the user is saying when the
user is upset or when the user is happy
is it the right time or not I think that
is the fundamental problem for example
the user might be getting a bit upset as
a human if I see somebody getting upset
then I will quickly clearly I will know
that oh I need to do something about
that person but for a machine only when
he is the person is totally upset then
only it might do something but you want
to really take an action when the user
is just started starting to getting
upset or maybe the user is good is in a
good mood maybe it's time you can
recommend something but how good how
good is the mood of that person so these
are the kind of problems that you have
to now understand and you have to figure
out just your sentiment analysis is not
enough you need to know the exact timing
the specific moment I think these kind
of things provide a level of empathy if
you can understand that very well it
rides level of empathy the body gets a
level of empathy with the user and
that's where the real usage of any kind
of BOTS mechanism is going to or any
kind of customer care automation for
that matter is going to increase so
there is a another issue with
conversational which is related to
conversation
so people are saying so many different
things they're sayings in so many
different ways so many intents out there
but sometimes they are also referring to
an older stuff sometimes Oh what
happened to that that returned that I
made what about that refund that I was
supposed to get last week and then you
are - supposed to know that the
conversation that he
talking about something that helped us
that happened last week so this is not a
new conversation this is an older
conversation so where is the
conversation coming to an end
and when she as humans we are very quick
in this we understand that sometimes the
conversation has you're talking about oh
we went to this really nice part last
week and you know we had a nice picnic
or there oh yeah everybody gets that but
you know you're talking to a bot then
then the bot needs to know that you are
talking referencing something from the
past and then you need to take out that
information and make sense out of that
and this is not a new conversation it's
an old conversation and then you are
also changing a lot of topics people
switch back and forth back and forth so
many times if you look at the data that
the way people are people talk people
switch back and forth between different
topics so understanding the tropics and
transitioning from one topic to another
basically again if I go back to that
older slide if you remember these are
different services so all these services
need to interplay they need to
constantly be is transitioning from one
to another now the user is striking we
work on tracking I just moved to returns
now has moved to refund and he wants to
eye on another product so these kind of
these kind of things need to happen very
quickly in this mechanism now this is
where we kind of in the retailer style
mimicking here we come into giving a
personality to the bot so not every bot
has to be the same many times different
corporations have different philosophy
depends upon what kind of stuff they
sell and what kind of customers visit
their stores and they want to portray a
totally different image so how do you
take that image onto a bot maybe on a
website if we can have different image
totally and you can have different style
of the website which is totally okay but
when you go to a bot the bot is just
talking so the only way you can convey
the different philosophies by the way he
says the bot says he or she I don't know
he or she or it say something and that
is where you want to mimic the style the
specifics language style of the
particular corporation or particular
organization there are of course
template template based mechanisms out
there but they are too rigid too brittle
there are some deep learning methods as
well but again the accuracy is not
guaranteed in those cases because you
might say something you don't want to
say and you lose the customer can shop
the bags expecting it to what I need is
another issue is the product decembe
equation so when you ask the maybe Alexa
has Masoud shipped maybe you are
thinking about the baby suit and but
when the Alexa is replying sure it has
your suit will arrive tomorrow it is
actually referring to a suit that you
had bought and maybe earlier so there is
a discrepancy there is a little
disconnect over here so knowing the
right product that what kind of product
you might be referring to and and that
particular point of time is extremely
important and this is part of this is
one of the things that needs to be done
before you can build you can understand
what the user is saying now when now we
are talking about net and template
templates is basically the style me
making again it's what we call as a
natural language generation template
based systems are not enough sometimes
it has to be a mix of the template
driven and some neural network based
systems and the combinations are what
generally tend to work better now the
other thing is sometimes the workflow of
a particular retailer may not be optimal
and you want to optimize that workflow
many companies for example you want to
make a return then you have to say
something for that returns and then it
goes to a particular server then it
looks up the return policy and then it
comes back and tells you this way this
is valid product returnable product or
not or maybe in certain cases
you need to optimize and your to find
out that okay just because you bought
this product and you are you are a good
customer you have been our customer for
the last 10 years which you can just
keep this product it's totally okay so
all that all these kind of decisions are
need to be optimized for each of these
companies and each of these companies
they have a different structure they
have different ways of doing it in fact
I remember just last week I was trying
to return a book from Amazon and I mean
Amazon customer for more than 20 years
and they just say keep it so I think
that kind of thing that kind of
optimizations don't need to happen in
the bot level as well where you can
quickly identify certain issues and tell
the user base based upon different kinds
of attributes of what that a user so now
we have talked a lot about the different
like intent mapping and sentiment
analysis and things like that but there
is the intelligence this is all stuff
like you can do entity extraction you
can do run a bit of LSD MMS you can run
a bit of SVM and so on where is the
intelligence coming from so if we pause
a little bit and try to think of this
story of six blind men and the elephant
I don't want to go into the story the
details of the story right now but the
moral of the story is perspective is
everything and if we think of
perspective it's a perspective really
that makes us intelligence it gives us
kind of an intelligence to us
so let's say if I if I go to a to a
friend and tell him that hey let's go
for a coffee and the next day I at and I
tell him that what happened I'm just
saying what happened but my friend will
know instantaneously was asking about
coffee now I go out to a stranger and I
tell him what happened and the stranger
has no idea what I'm talking about
and as far as I am concerned as far as
that stranger is concerned there is very
little intelligence over there but in
the case of when I'm talking to a friend
he knows everything about me and what
had asked
and what I am referring to and he makes
an instant decision based upon that
particular thing so that is what we call
his perspective but can BOTS have
perspective and the answer is yes we can
provide BOTS with the perspective and
the perspectives context
once you have context then you can
pretty much build a lot of things around
that you can give a semblance of
intelligence to the bot and in fact
context is the central thing to what we
are what we do context is the base of
all our workflows it is the base for all
of our natural language understanding
and natural language generation what is
context context is has just deeper
information about you as a person about
the products about the company's
specific company it has a deep
information about workflows it has all
the algorithms that sit there they're
just producing different kinds of
attributes about all these things
constantly and of course there are the
you know derived types there are the
real-time types then there are the
simple types I mean this is pretty
straightforward if you look at them but
taking if you take all of these and if
you take a lot of all of the user data
there is a large number of hundreds of
attributes that you can calculate about
the user in hundreds of attributes you
can calculate about the products and
about the company itself about the
workflow itself and this is where we say
that the bot is thinking I mean this is
our our language I mean the way we kind
of say it it's the what is thinking
because it now knows something about you
it now say it when it say something
there's a huge difference so when you're
when you give a book of Shakespeare to
eight-year-old and he reads a sentence
doesn't make sense to that he might read
that sentence you might say a sentence
out of Shakespeare doesn't make sense
sense at all but now you're a 30 year
old person now you read that sentence it
makes a lot of sense so all that time
you're spent in your education all
everything that is all context that
makes you intelligent so these are the
some some of these types some of the
things for example
that we calculate all the time there are
a lot of abdicate information a lot of
information which is very simple so
username franchisor ID I mean these are
pretty simple information and some of
the way we also track things like the
number of failed conversations and
because because based upon the number of
failed conversations you can pretty much
rate how and the new conversation is
going to look like and these are again
some of the example items so number of
active orders out there and how many
artists a person has placed so lifetime
purchase values again an important thing
by which you can make a lot of decisions
about the user and these are simple ones
because you know they are just in point
and you are not doing any aggregations
of course lifetime purchase has an
aggregation to it now when you have so
many different kinds of context
now which context is important so this
is again a lot of machine learning again
comes up over here because now we want
to identify this specific context that
is relevant to what you are saying how
which so they are probably of a few
hundreds of context the one particular
context is that is relevant to you you
have to go through them and identify
that particular context and apply it and
then make the right energy decision to
say something useful to the user and of
course probably run a service in the
background and do a return or something
like that so these in this particular
case you have to identify a lot of
relevant entities you have to identify
the best entities that are that are
possible and which ones you need to
apply and yeah there's a lot of science
to it a lot of art to this particular
piece and one of the more again a very
central piece that happens in a bot so I
have gone through all the different
challenges that you know general
customer care automation
we'll face and has faith I mean we also
face that the future actually is that if
we can optimize the workflows if we can
take all the workflows that different
companies have optimized them on the fly
we can if you can take all the companies
different kinds of data from companies
and make sure that the integration also
is happening very quickly and we add to
all of the data to all the different
context within our system I think that's
some of the future which I feel overall
the industry might move words with that
I think thank you
that's pretty much what I wanted to say
and let me know I'm remembering the time
when we used to call for customer
service and then they started automation
but then there's always that last bit
there like press zero to talk to a
person and most people just do that so
there was like I'm sure the improvements
and the technology to try to encourage
people to do the automation part so I'm
just wondering how you if you've you
know dealt with that or if you can talk
about how to do that with chatbots yes
so typically what is done is that you
try to engage the sentiment of the user
and if it is going towards extreme
negative if you sense that it is it has
been let's say if the user has been
generally a positive question throughout
and now as you can see a slight shift in
the way he's saying things it's a good
time to hand over to actual human in
certain cases depending again again
depends upon what's the lifetime value
of that particular customer but in
certain cases you might want the bot to
answer because maybe it's totally okay
for that and again a lot depends upon a
lot of for example context comes up
you're here because you want to know
what kind of things he has bought if it
is like thing that has been maybe $2
item or $3 item okay let the bot answer
but he he has bought a TV for $4,000 TV
then of course you want very quick
things to happen so I think it's the
same philosophy that goes in stores so
if you go in a grocery store or safe a
kind of store the feel is tomoow
somewhat different but if you go into a
high-end Best Buy kind of store the feel
is different based upon the kind of
products you're buying and the kind of
you know interaction that is supposed to
happen there
[Music]